and now it's time for bomb reviews with
Chester a bomb
tonight's review Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles out of the shadows oh my god
this is the greatest movie I've ever
seen in my life heroes in a half
spoilers dear c4 Turtles code the
Turtles
and the movie is nice enough to
literally spell out their names in the
opening I'm so glad the movie did that I
always confuse them with other Ninja
Turtles and they do all sorts of cool
radical ninja things like watch
basketball games in the ceiling i watch
the basketball game in the ceiling once
the Hornets have very good lawyers but
they're upset because they see that
Bojack vermin is taking all their credit
dude how can those people believe that
she took down the shredder
I knew crazy right no really how could
they believe that we learn that defeats
a robotic shred inator like keep it for
a movie made for five-year-olds even the
five-year-olds would be able to buy that
but they will be able to buy crushed
soda
Nike shoes and Apple products apparently
the only things that exist in New York
no seriously look for Coke Reebok or PC
they don't exist
maybe shredders plan was to get rid of
competitive marketing speaking of
shredder he's in cahoots with a
scientist named Blaster Stockman and
he's trying to get shredder out of jail
or at least I think it's the shredder
because he should or does not look like
that shadowy guy from the first one fact
I will take an angry eggplants but this
guy looks like an actor who's not trying
and speaking of Metra Megan Fox runs
into an ex detective named Casey Jones
and she's like who you I'm you what I
thought Casey Jones was supposed to be a
rough badass he is but they just cast a
straight arrow instead and why do you
say you're like me because I am I'm
good-looking eye candy I have a dream I
can't quite reach I want people to take
me seriously even though they don't I'm
pretty much just your character with a
penis and I'm actually trying hey I'm
trying yes you know how they hang a flag
at half-mast
that your performance right now hey I'm
a very serious credible actress now let
me slip into my kids like your uniform
to get some information wait you need a
few seconds couldn't you just bump into
that guy I mean you can pretend you with
someone else and pretend you're someone
else you do a Baxter Stockman Google
uniform
why are we so comfortable that a pervert
is producing kids movies PG
mariya don't mmm the miniskirts to give
the information to fight the evil brain
or over there you speaking of brains
Krang is in this movie and he kidnaps
the shredder and he tonight you work for
me
okey and that's not an abbreviation that
is the entire scene in fact I think it
stretched it out a bit
the shredder comes across two guys named
bebop and Rocksteady once a guy who
occasionally will do a Finnish accent
and the other dresses are certain away
only because it was in the cartoon
seriously even hipsters are like dude
even Prince wouldn't be cutting that too
soon but Krang and shredder this purple
ooze and it reduces people down to their
evolutionary animal I bet you didn't
know we evolve from rhinos and warthogs
it just makes so much sense I mean in
the cartoon they acted like the animal
they are around the most that's the one
they were mutate like but no it's
evolution but not only that this zoos
can apparently turn the Turtles into
humans Oh what are they gonna do with it
nothing total MacGuffin goes nowhere
it's like watching Bruce Wayne
throughout an entire movie think about
being Batman but instead he makes pies
but it's okay because Donatello with the
purple stuff to Jack bebop and
rocksteady wherever they are the world
really seriously guys I'm high you say
Kate you're making the cartoon look
credible so they try to stop them but
they failed oh because Leo couldn't keep
the family together because if there's
one constant and all the incarnations of
Ninja Turtles is that Leonardo is always
a horrible leader how many times does he
have to be told what a good leader is by
someone who's a much better leader why
doesn't that person lead thinking of
leaving Krang is about to take over the
world and shredder is like I trusted you
I thought we were gonna be partners dude
I'm a talking clitoris with pinkies
we've only know each other a few seconds
why would you trust me I don't know
obvious moral about family yeah whatever
I'm gonna freeze you and turn you into a
Smash Brothers trophy wet but the
turtles stopped crying and the evil
shreds to call Jen that ain't no job
back to we never said it was Dimension X
and the turtles are finally accepting
kinda-sorta
as police we applaud you give you the
key to the city and yet we're not gonna
tell anybody about you yeah it's kind of
weird the whole movie we want to be
human but now we're just kind of like no
really this allow we can find out about
each other I need about science and DNA
in evolution new we will stay in the
shadows and the best hiding spot
possible in the torch of the Statue of
Liberty towel what the end so after the
shadows was a
have fun even though I think the writers
were smoking the same thing I was
smoking but it's silly enough for you
little kid oh I mean uh 13 and above
yeah yeah it's a gritty stuff here we
adult
this is jittery bum seeing guys yeah
yeah change I can I have a guy away yes
tomorrow
James come on okay Tyler Perry in the
sequin Madea
the secret of use